by the financial crisis Australia didn't
suffer this Carla didn't suffer this
some of the other major countries didn't
suffer this country suffered because
Gordon Brown sold gold just as prop of
the social services how can you stand
there and say you didn't overspend and
end up bankrupting this country that is
absolutely ludicrous you frankly just
lying so I guess I'm not going to
convince you to butter we're not going
to convince me decide that the facts
speaks themselves you stood there and
said you didn't overspend if I get to
the end of the week I can't afford to
buy a pint
I've overspent it means I am tightening
money Rachel we've got the end of a
government of 13 years and during that
13 year period you spent spent you sold
gold when it was low if we saw the gold
now would be pretty much better off you
can't stand that and so now I just have
like one point do mate but just I think
I'm not gonna give video if it's a
millstone right well nobody happened
under the law let me come back on this
because you said something very
important which is that other some other
countries didn't suffer from that now
that's because they were less exposed to
financial services so Paula I'm sorry
I'm a financial services financial
services actually put millions and
millions and millions of pounds into
this country millions of pounds which
you then spend I spend ear is no alleged
point there there's a poignant because I
think that we didn't do enough of was
build up other industries offshore
financial service is important including
here in Leeds but look the reality is
that we didn't do not enough on
apprenticeships we didn't do enough of a
modern industrial policy and we're not
doing enough now one industry and so my
point is as you need a more diverse and
more diverse industrial base and that is
also at stake in this election all right
I'll come to you